where do i even begin
i was gushing about record of ragnarok a
couple months ago
i made a video on it and i praised the
manga for being the best battle manga
i've personally ever read
something i still believe to this day if
you haven't read it or
haven't watched that video i recommend
it before continuing with this one
because despite record of ragnarok's
simplicity in its concept
or perhaps because of how
straightforward it is every single one
of its fights are
beautiful from beginning to end be it
because of the two enemies their
history their chemistry together or the
actual fighting
and then netflix swooped in if there is
a single thing that brought this anime
down to its knees
and pummeled it into the dirt it's the
animation
record of ragnarok again is so simple
that there are very few things you need
to get right
except for the animation after all it's
just fighting
if the fighting doesn't look good then
the entire battle show
falls apart and that's sadly what
happened
there are great parts especially in the
animation of facial expressions for
example
and close-ups on characters but that's
just about the only parts where it
visually shines
it turned the epic finale of adam vs
zeus into
a literal slideshow people will joke
around how any anime with bad animation
quality is a slideshow but this was
literally just still frames next to each
other in the last and most epic
moments of one of the best fights in the
show
and in this video i wanted to talk about
the entirety of the adam vs zeus fight
because in my opinion it is the poster
child of record of ragnarok
it is the one that stands above all for
me
and though i will mention all of the bad
parts that netflix failed to translate
from the manga
i'm not one to completely crap on an
anime if there's merit present
and there is one that must be
acknowledged
must be is the soundtrack adam versus
begins with one of the most absurd and
charismatic introductions to the fight
with zeus's entrance with hermes and the
music playing behind him
the stupid dancing i was super excited
to see how this ended up being animated
and this was probably the only part of
the anime that
truly exceeded my expectations the music
at this part the background sound was
masterfully done the mix of classic
beethoven
and heavy rock music was just so awesome
so epic to build up to this fight
[Applause]
the way they clash completely yet work
in harmony is really hard to achieve
and to go along with it we see the
totally absurd yet entertaining antics
of zeus as he gets hyped up
midway through the crowd starts cheering
for him as the grandfather of the cosmos
and this
really is just icing on the cake with
the rock music
classical cheers everything works so
well together here
really hats off and even separate from
this scene specifically the ost
never fails in record of ragnarok it has
ancient
and time period fitting music in the
flashbacks
it has great rock music one of the
biggest attributes of this anime for the
fights
with that thumping drum to back it up it
is epic
and emotional and sinister whenever it
needs to be
the soundtrack is the single part of
this anime that really went above and
beyond to the levels that
i was expecting from this great
adaptation or what should have been
great
and it's no surprise considering
yasuhara takanashi the composer behind
works like fairy tale and naruto
shippuden was responsible for it same
goes for the voice acting honestly with
even more huge names like kazuhiro
yamaji and junichi suave
all prominent voice actors but the
animation
once once again i must bring it up
really
really disappointed and it's not even
like the animation is objectively bad
but this manga brought so much hype and
record of ragnarok
deserves god tier animation it's the
bare minimum for the amazing fights that
it has
the production quality has to match that
and it didn't
the one word i would use to describe it
is inconsistent
as i said earlier facial expressions are
done very well
the conniving loki the expressions of
zeus and his fight with adam
but then you'll snap away to a broader
shot that can
barely even be considered as animation i
swear manga panels move better than some
of these scenes
and they don't even move for example the
dramatic and epic kick from zeus is
barely even animated you've got the hype
staging for the scene right you can see
just how powerful this kick is gonna be
but the momentum the speed and strength
it all disappears in the next shot
as adam jumps over it like it's nothing
and look yeah part of the point is to
show that adam is
leagues ahead of zeus at this point but
that does not excuse this
poor animation that reduces what should
be an epic moment of atom flexing
to what barely feels like an important
scene
and really the saving grace of this
fight aside from the soundtrack and the
voice acting
is the original writing for it because
despite the inconsistent animation
i still felt the epicness of adam
fighting for all of mankind
the sentiment was still there i could
feel the pride of adam fighting for all
of his children
i mean truly this quote
it still holds up i mentioned it in my
old video too
and it still gave me goosebumps when
it's animated which
reminds me of just how much of a shame
it is that the animation
couldn't match that record of ragnarok
has such a prolific soundtrack it's
almost
always going throughout the show and in
the few moments where it's not there
like this
one it makes it feel super epic
and we continue through the fight and i
want to say once again the animation
isn't completely bad
there are great shots and still scenes
with little movement are done
very well but the way they're connected
is horrendous and of course that is what
makes animation
like adam grabs zeus's head finally
setting up for a comeback after we think
all is lost and then
we boot up microsoft powerpoint like
what
the end of the fight is also perfect
adam's admirable silhouette
standing against the sky as he dies
fighting for his children
the emotions and cheers of the crowd
it's it's all very beautiful
but it's not enough to make up for the
ultimately disappointing fight that
built up to it
now if i were to rate everything i would
give soundtrack and voice acting a 10.
totally they never disappointed honestly
and story and writing i would give a
solid 8 as well in my opinion the
emotions that i felt reading the manga
what the writer really wanted to get
through
were translated into the anime the key
points
the luboob versus thor fight in my
opinion was pretty underwhelming but i
thought the same in the manga as well
it's kind of just two chads fighting it
out
it's good to introduce everything but
not much more than that
but the standout moments i did remember
from adam versus were still there and so
i have to give credit
and animation i'd give it a 3.
and you might think that's a little
harsh because there are good moments
but the thing is record of ragnarok
deserved
better it's not just that the animation
is objectively bad or mid-tier
but it didn't meet the level that was
required for such an intense battle
manga
and that lowered it significantly it's
different if this animation were in a
slice of life or a drama or a mystery
but it's in record of ragnarok and that
is important
and overall enjoyment i'd give it a 6.5
i think that despite what happened
animation wise the soundtrack
writing and voice acting really carried
this anime for me
i still felt hype even when it was frame
by frame and i definitely attribute it
to that
it creates a really strong atmosphere
from start to finish
i'm not sure how people who haven't read
the manga feel i don't feel like they
would have liked it as much as i did
but i was both disappointed and
impressed at different parts
overall though i'm indifferent
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you